we know that brain health depends on
proper nutrition and so when we see
people who have nutritional deficiencies
maybe for example having not enough
vitamin b12 or missing certain fats like
the omega-3 fats in their diet we see
that there's a vastly increased risk of
illnesses like depression and anxiety we
also know that in clinical trials we can
we can use those nutrients to actually
treat brain illnesses like depression
and dementia so every good psychiatric
evaluation involves some lab testing
just to make sure that the basic
physiology things like your thyroid your
B vitamin levels the amount of potassium
and sodium in your body that those are
normal for a lot of people they are but
for some people they aren't and those
are instantly reversible deficiencies so
for example if you have an iron
deficiency you're just you're going to
be sluggish you're going to have a brain
fog you're not going to feel well it's
interesting we sort of start with
evaluation in labs when really part of
my work has been how do we get food into
the conversation and so I can assess you
with a lab test but for example if you
never eat wild salmon or mussels or any
good fatty fish that's a good source of
those long-chain omega-3 fats we know
that your levels are going to be low and
so really we can learn a lot about
someone's nutritional status just by
asking them simple questions it doesn't
require expensive testings in our clinic
we simply ask people what they eat for
breakfast lunch and dinner and that
that's really the goal of my book II
complete is helping people walking them
through nutritional assessment it's
called the simple food assessment just
because it's simple and thinking about
what are your challenges at every meal
and what are the nutrients and the foods
most importantly the foods that are
missing we know that there are these
very important nutrient dense foods
they're foods that have more nutrients
for your brain per calorie and we want
those nutrients because you use them to
make everything in your brain I mean if
you think about every molecule in your
brain starts at the end of your fork and
so really it's what I love about food
and clinical practice I'm a psychiatrist
is that it gives us an intervention that
really you can focus on an employee
every day and it's a way that we can
help patients and people in general take
care of themselves really employ self
here with every bite so that's the idea
behind nutritional psychiatry is it's
being called so a lot of times we focus
on super foods or singular foods I
focused a lot of my work on kale but
really what we want to think is is in
food categories and what I see in
clinical practice over and over again is
these same food categories are missing
in people's diets and when we look at
the the eater landscape in America what
we see is that people are really missing
some of these key nutrients that are
they're eating very call it the beige
diet or the 12 year old boy diet like
lots of highly processed foods not a lot
of colors we want to get people having
more of those rainbows on their plates
so the food categories that I really
love to see people put back into their
diet when it comes to eating for brain
health we'd love to see the leafy greens
so things like kale I've got some some
watercress right here that a
particularly liked very very nutrient
dense green and by nutrient dense that's
a very important concept as much more
importantly calories calories really
only help us calculate nutrient density
and nutrient density is the bang for
your box something like this water crest
it's going to be under 30 calories for a
whole cup and with this or any other
leafy green you're going to get so much
vitamin K vitamin C vitamin A you're
going to get fighter fiber and you're
going to get these phytonutrients those
are molecules and plants that we
understand they're much more powerful
than just antioxidants so leafy greens
and crunchy vegetables or we call them
the rainbow vegetables you want to look
at your plate and you know see colors
right you want to see greens and reds
and oranges because each of those colors
represent a different federal nutrient a
different palette of Medicine as it were
a lot of those powerful phytonutrients
they're what color a plant so we know
everything with red like that red pepper
has lycopene just like a tomato in the
watermelon so colorful fruits and
vegetables and leafy greens and then the
category that so many people are missing
is seafood so we want to get more wild
fish particularly small fish like
anchovies and sardines and there are all
kinds of really fun creative ways to do
this I love to prescribe ceviche because
it's a no cook way of doing food
something like a scallop or shrimp just
in lime juice and so in terms of the
nutrients so what are we trying to get
into people's diets when we get Tim to
eat more of these leave
greens and seafood and we're getting
much more of these long-chain omega-3
fats those are very critical for brain
health the longest DHA is actually what
brain cells are made of and then others
the EPA for example is a very
interesting fat that helps kind of thin
the blood imagine that your your Bloods
kind of silky smooth and that's that's
obviously very important in terms of
delivering oxygen to the brain and also
preventing vascular disease as you age
other nutrients that we just want to see
a lot of in people's diets we want to
see more fiber just more plants because
as we understand the connection between
the gut and the brain you can't you
can't have a healthy brain without a
healthy gut I mean everybody just knows
that I think a little intuitively right
when you don't feel well down here you
don't you don't feel well up here we
also understand there's a lot of
crosstalk between the brain and the gut
just literally hundreds of thousands of
neurons nerve cells that communicate
back and forth between the brain and the
God and we know when the gut has certain
bacteria living in it the bacteria that
really get fostered and are promoted to
grow when you eat more plants and more
crunchy plants and more fermented foods
that's one of a key nutrients that often
gets left out of the conversation fiber
because gut health is so key
so omega-3 fats the B vitamins vitamin
b12 which the food category for that are
going to be mussels clams and oysters
just find very high concentrations of
both b12 and other minerals that are
important for the brain like zinc is one
of my favorites and so the idea behind
nutritional psychiatry and behind eat
complete is how do we look at what
nutrients are missing and then translate
that into food so instead of telling
people hey you should eat more iron you
say hey you know what a surprising food
is that's full of iron our clams right
or another great source of iron our are
these cashews is one of my favorite
because along with leafy greens and
seafood I want to get a lot of nuts
so almonds cashews here's a nice almond
full of vitamin E and then these are
some of my favorite medicines in my
clinic these are these are pumpkin seeds
and pumpkin seeds are pepitas are great
for three nutrients ink magnesium and
then tryptophan tryptophan is the amino
acid that we
use to make serotonin and dopamine these
are very very important mood regulating
and learning regulating
neurotransmitters or chemicals in the
brain and so that the idea is to give
people a core set of foods so you know
again with every bite you're getting all
the nutrients that your brain needs